j'ai toujours rêvé de pouvoir laisser
quelque chose
une femme à mark martin beauregard a
décidé de s'attaquer à un problème en
apparence banale mais qui empoisonnent
la vie de ceux qui se déplacent en
fauteuil roulant grâce à cette rampe
ils pourront en fait entrer dans
certains commerces sans ce but et à la
petite marche qui se trouve à l'entrée
et qui représente une grande barrière
mais voilà ça fonctionne
merveilleusement dit martin beauregard a
fondé son propre organisme appelé accès
grâce à une subvention de 5000 $ il a
distribué gratuitement 15 rames
fabriquées sur mesure à des commerçants
de la garnison 9
ils pourront les installer quand un
client fauteuil roulant va se présenter
moi je rentrerai mais la plupart du
temps ces magasins spécialisés là j'irai
pas accès une solution simple pour que
les petits commerces de quartier
devienne accessible
ça donne un choix ça donne aussi je te
dirai fierté de rentrer par la même
porte que tout le monde au lieu d'être
obligé de rentrer par en arrière en deux
containers à déchets et pour les
commerçants c'est une façon d'augmenter
la clientèle pendant le proposition mal
tout ce qu on accepte ça ne faisait pas
plaisir parce qu'on avait des fois des
handicapés qui venait puis on les aider
à rentrer à l'intérieur du commerce
le ça va être plus facile dont l'heure
de jeu à mettre la rampe ce sera en
sécurité
le projet pilote a aussi d'autres
bienfaits
on dizaines de jeunes ont fabriqué les
rampes aux ateliers d'antoine une
entreprise de réinsertion sociale qui
offre des formations en ébénisterie
projets valorisants c'est un projet qui
vraiment aide la communauté contribue à
son bien-être
les participants sont encore plus fier
et s'applique bien plus haut c'est
espérer d'une initiative qui existe déjà
à toronto
c'est la fondation stop gap mis sur pied
par ce torontois il ya quatre ans qui a
eu l'idée de concevoir ses rampes près
de 500 commerces de la ville reine en
ont maintenant une et l'initiative en
inspirer plus d'un
à montréal un autre groupe appelé
j'accède québec distribue aussi des
rampes
il en a déjà donné une vingtaine au
total notamment à des commerçants de la
plaza st-hubert et des environs merci
l'organisme a aussi décidé d'en offrir
eu mon restaurant chez alexandre il ce
n'est pas un hasard
on a pensé à chez alexandre pour la pour
le symbole pour ce qui s'est passé l'été
dernier avec toute la polémique
pour omar l'achète des son organisation
il faut privilégier la collaboration
plutôt que la confrontation avec les
commerçants les personnes handicapées
les personnes à mobilité réduite font
partie du problème peut aussi faire
partie de la solution
les petits trempe pourraient se
multiplier dans la métropole
j'accède québec veut en offrir 200 l'an
prochain et axel organismes de martin
beauregard content donné 500 notre
mandat c'est de trouver des solutions
simples temporaire en espérant qu'un
jour on se rende à l'accessibilité
universelle
mais en attendant les deux organisations
ont besoin de subventions et de
commandites pour poursuivre leur marche